So going forward, these days much of
strong label recognition is really
machine learning applied to patterns
of pixel intensities, or features.
And to cover this, as I said, would
require a deep understanding of machine
learning, and a class or
17 of them to learn that.
So, instead, what we'll do is we're
going to focus on sort of two general
principals called generative
versus discriminative methods, and
their application and the representation
used in computer vision.
And then we'll spend some time on
activity recognition from video because
why recognize pictures when you
can actually recognize activity.
And besides that,
it's how I earn my tenure.
All right.
Talk to you soon.